I'm Zaman Daanish I work at next-gen at
the moment I'm there
Chuya expert I've been working with
Julia for around six years in graphics
and GPU acceleration and on the plotting
infrastructure today I will talk about
what julia is and when to use it I will
talk quite a bit about how to call other
libraries and a bit about the
performance of Julia compared to other
languages I will talk a bit about how to
write nice composable libraries and
Julia and how it's unique in that regard
and I collected a few noteworthy
examples to give you a taste of how
Julia looks like and I will finish with
a little demo of how you can call Julia
from Python and discuss a bit like the
disadvantages of Julia and this is all
in next journal the company we I work at
so it's a notebook platform where you
can run Julia and Python in the cloud
and it also has a presentation mode
which I will be using right does this
work huh nope
ok so what is Julia I usually describe
it as Python at the speed of C with very
elegant syntax for math for like from
MATLAB so you get all the dynamic
features from Python and the
interactivity at the speed of C and I
think it combines these the advantages
of these languages it's also a
multi-purpose like Python and
multi-paradigm language so you can
combine more functional approaches with
more object-oriented approaches it
appeared in 2012 so it's pretty young
compared to Python
but it's also already pretty usable and
mature and steadily growing then my
favorite feature lists from Julia is
that it inherited quite a bit of goodies
from lists like fully featured macros
that you can treat code as a data
structure so you can just manipulate it
like any other data structure and eval
it and a lot of functional programming
inheritance one of the most noteworthy
features is multiple dispatch in Julia
where you can compose multiple function
very nicely by not just dispatching on
one argument but dispatching on the type
of multiple arguments in your function I
will talk a bit more about it later and
I really enjoy the optional type system
and Julia because it doesn't get in your
way if you're just writing something but
if you actually sit down and want to
write a mature library it's really nice
to have a fully features type system and
Sheree has a lot of introspection and
reflection functions so you can look
actually at what code regenerates down
to the assembly code you can look where
functions are defined you can
immediately get their source code and
things like that and get help for
function which makes it very easy to get
started with Sharia I tried to make a
little graph about when to use Chuya and
where it's used so here on this axis I
have like the theoretically niceness of
Trias features in this area and here I
try to roughly estimate how many
projects there are in julia at this
moment and why I said theoretically nice
it's because the more projects they are
in an area the easier it will be to use
and the less awkward so it if it's not
theoretically it would just be like a
straight diagonal because if there's
only one person using Julia X for
example for a hard real-time this there
won't be many libraries for it and will
be awkward and
this is kind of the case for machine
learning I think enjoy because julia has
very incredible features for machine
learning because it's fast it has very
good GPU integration but not many people
use it for machine learning at the
moment so there are definitely libraries
missing the strong part is more in
scientific computing julia was created
for this and for optimization problems
shreya has a long history and
optimizations with jump which was a very
successful library early on and it
probably offers the state of the art for
solving optimization problems and there
are a lot of physics and simulation
projects with finite element simulations
and probably julia gets its most money
from big finance company doing finance
modeling and nowadays there are quite a
few climate modeling projects in you
wish Julia
so in this era here I can definitely say
you should take a look at Julia if you
work in this if you go more into this
area I'm like okay Julia might be great
for this but there are not as many
mature libraries yet some people use
julia in production with web servers but
yeah you won't have all the libraries
there and some of them aren't very
mature the same is true for desktop
applications not all of them are nicely
wrapped yet QT there's a wrapper but
it's not well maintained and things like
that but there are desktop applications
so it does work hard real time is an
interesting one because julia is a
garbage collected language which usually
doesn't work as well with a hard
real-time but since you can fairly
easily write through your code without
doing any allocations you can actually
use it for hard real time but I think
there's only one project that is
actually doing that so there's not much
data about it how nice it is actually in
the end and here it's like in the bottom
corner that's something that doesn't
really work injury so if you're
to target iOS tria doesn't run on iOS
I'm not sure when it will run on iOS on
Android actually like I think two weeks
ago it started running on Android but
it's still in an early phase so there's
not much to say about it if it will be
nice and for really secure application
where you probably want to prove that
your program is back free and things
like that Korea isn't the right language
it's not battle proved in this and yeah
now julia is very famous for its
performance that's what it's known for
so that's definitely one of the biggest
use cases and you can see this nicely on
the slide here it's a few micro
benchmarks compared to other languages
the baseline here is C and you can see
that Julia really nicely is around the C
performance and I think you can even go
as far as that this is like variants
around it that you would get a similar
variance between different C compiler
versions so it's usually very close and
in all my years
comparing C Andrea performance it was
usually back if Julia didn't reach the
same performance now why is performance
important I hear a lot there have been a
lot of articles about like yeah I don't
care
Python is fast enough why should I think
about this and my main reason for this
is that I want to set on a language
where now that I don't have any barrier
in the future because probably the
moment where you run into a problem you
have like a lot of deadlines and you
want to really finish your projet and
suddenly you notice
[ __ ] the performance doesn't work out
it's unusable that's probably the worst
moment where you want to switch
languages so I try to set on a language
where this won't happen it's relatively
easy to write Python code that runs as
fast as C because it actually calls out
to a lot of underlying C libraries
that has been working out really well in
Python I think and combines the best of
the two worlds but someone has to write
those libraries and those people
probably also want to have a nice
language to write in and sometimes it's
just really awkward to express your
program in terms of calling out to a see
library because you need to use plain
data types like arrays and numbers and
need to get rid of classes probably and
all the nice things you started loving
about Python and now finally when people
consider switching to Julia they will
say well I have all these nice libraries
but jury actually has very nice foreign
function interface for most major
languages and one of the best developed
one is actually Pike also for calling
Python and that's because historically
the Julia and the Python community have
been working a lot together there's been
a lot of people working together on this
so what can you do by using pike or you
can just import any installed Python
package you can define julia callbacks
and just feed them into a python
function here this is just another
syntax in julia to have a short form of
a callback and this works just like
passing a c function to pythons so it
will have a similar performance you can
also even inherit from python classes so
this is a julia macro that gives you
this kind of hybrid domain-specific
language between julia and python to
define a python class that inherits from
the polynomial from numpy and then you
can just use it like a normal julia type
but also pass it to any Python function
that accepts an polynomial
and you can even write hole functions in
with this kind of string macro here this
will immediately execute this in Python
and define this pie map so that's just a
very simple function it maps this
function f over the array B and writes
it out to a the result and we can wrap
this in julia here and create the stria
function PI map which we then can
compare to the julia in build so this is
a funny little syntax here with the dot
notation that you can apply any julia
function to any julia array and it was
just it's pretty much like a map and it
has a lot of nice properties but I'm not
going more deeply into this yeah the
same is true for calling C so we have
this little C snippet above there which
implements the same function so it's
also a map implementation you can shell
out to compile this little c function
into a shared library and the code to
actually call the c function is a bit
more complicated because it's
aesthetically typed language so you
actually need to define with what types
you call this function and you need to
define the arguments types and the
return types of the function you're
calling but then you can just call the C
functions just like any julia function
and it will work without any overhead
and finally there's also c++ wrapper
library called CX xjl it's a bit more
complicated because c++ is much more
complicated so it actually also allows
you veer the string macro to define
arbitrary C++ code which is very handy
if you want to wrap more complex C++
libraries with templates and classes
and then you can also call this C++
function with the CX x macro and call it
just like any normal julia function now
let's talk a bit about performance since
all those wrappers like even the pike or
episode not have any overhead it will
just convert the array to an umpire
array I think without any copies same is
true for the C functions so it's
possible to benchmark those codes from
inside juje without any overhead and I'm
using benchmarks tools which tries
really hard to make statistically
significant benchmarks it's a bit
awkward to call here but that's how it
looks and now if we compare this we see
that python takes 55 seconds for this
simple math c and c++ are around 1.1
seconds and julia is a bit faster than
that two times faster i think so
in an extreme case this is definitely an
extreme case julia can be 600 times
faster than Python for such simple
things
why is Julia faster than C++ and she
obviously you can get the same
performance and C because it's very
close to the hardware so you can always
get the top performance but I think it's
missing some sim D optimization which is
a bit harder to get and C and I didn't
figure out the correct command line
flags to get it but if you play around
it you will get the same performance as
julia now can we go faster than this and
the answer is yes julia has pretty nice
threading integration this at frets
macro existed for quite a bit of time
and with julia 1.3 which got released a
few months ago this threading
infrastructure is way better nowadays
but also a bit more complicated so i'm
not going to talk about it today but
yeah you
can just make loop threaded with this
macro and be even 2 times faster than
the fastest Julia before and sensory has
a very nice GPU integration you can even
easily move things to the GPU and then
call the already existing met function
and be even faster after that what I
want to point out here is that this
actually does compile Giulia functions
to the GPU so you it's not restricted to
some arbitrary set and cue arrays but
you can call rack your own Julianne's
and map them of an array or write your
own CUDA kernels in Giulia while using
all the nice abstractions from julia
which is pretty unique now that means
utilizing all these tools in julia you
can be up to 180 times faster than the c
solution of course that's not fair of
course you could go to C and also go
through all these hoops and call out to
the GPU but I think what I want to point
out here is that in julia is very easy
and you just have all these tools
readily available and the takeaway from
this is druid us offer state of the art
performance it's relatively simple to
get there and it has great interrupts
there's also even Java CO and our call
and you can call to MATLAB which I
haven't showed and while offering all of
this it still stays interactive and fun
now in the last two years or so there
has been a new motto been forged in the
julia community is come for the
performance stay for the syntax before
because a lot of people were actually
like yeah I really need this performance
of Sharia that's why I'm using it then
they were writing more and more
libraries and they were more excited
about the actual syntax which features
and how you compose code and Julia
and that it's actually nice to have a
type system compared to just having
everything untyped and multiple dispatch
has been come up as a very nice way to
compose code and extend existing
libraries and I hope that this isn't too
much code to simply point out what I'm
talking about
so above here we define a module that's
how you can structure your Giulia code
and isolated modules you can have
abstract types in Giulia which are
defined like that then you can have
concrete types
I already made a more advanced concrete
type with a type parameter that means
these fields can take on any type but
they need to be the same one here and it
inherits from an abstract color now in
Giulia instead of binding methods to the
object you actually just overload
functions so here you just overload the
base tuple function to convert your RGB
value to a tuple and then you can also
overload the plus operator here and this
syntax says overload this for the
argument T for all T that are inheritant
of abstract color and then we just
convert to a tuple do the plus with a
tuple and creating your instance of the
type T and having this base package
means we can very easily define a new
type like a new color space for example
that inherits from abstract color and
all we need to do is define this tuple
conversion and we get the plus for free
so this just works out of the box and
that makes it very easy to combine
packages especially because you then can
just put it into a sum function which
just expect your data type in the array
to have plus defined for it so this
works out of the box
and what's also pretty outstanding in
Julia is that it has the same
performance as built-in types so when
you compare this to building the sum
over three times as many floats you will
see it has almost the same performance
as doing it with the more complex types
that reps three floats and that means
you can actually define your own number
types if you want to track your accuracy
in assimilation and things like that or
dual types complex types they don't need
to be built in an julia to actually be
fast
now some catch examples i selected from
data science this is the
state-of-the-art csv pazzo which is by
now in performance on power on the most
on the on par with the fastest CSV
powers there are data frames is yeah
obviously the data frame library in
julia and there's plots which is the go
to plotting packages and stat plots is
actually just an extension of plots and
it's very similar to this extension
caller extension thing i showed you so
just extending plots by a few more
functions and this kind of
domain-specific syntax to more concisely
make statistically statistical plots and
i don't I mean you can have a look at it
I won't go through this I will also
publish the slides so you can probably
look at it in more detail compared to it
there's also queried Oh Jo and quite a
few other data transforming packages
this one uses Julia's macros to define a
domain-specific language have a more
concise way of defining data
transformation and it's tightly
integrated with Vega light for plotting
I saw that works very well together
I think everyone just needs to find out
which style I prefer more and there
quite a few joyeux libraries for that
jury also has a neural network library
which is called flux its features
compared roughly to watch tensorflow
offers mostly it's as fast but because
there are fewer people working on it
there definitely some performance bugs
it uses the Giulia GPU acceleration
infrastructure which allows the
framework to be 100% written in Giulia
while still having GPU acceleration and
last time I checked it was the
implementation was around 2000 lines of
code so it's really approachable you can
actually go in there and look at the
code and understand what's going on
which is very nice if you need to debug
something and it also works worth
playing through your arrays types and
functions because usually you can't do
that because you need some GPU
acceleration but because RIA can
actually compile those functions for the
GPU and also has some pretty good
automatic differentiation for custom
functions you can use those in your
layers this is how it looks like just to
give you a taste there are many more
examples like this in the flux model zoo
if you are interested in this library
and yeah I think it's a very promising
library because I know I don't know if
you know the tens of flow and Swift
project but it's very similar to that
because it's actually using compiler
plugins instead of writing a new
compiler around it to get good
performance and that's where we come to
hook into the compiler because julia
actually allows you to hook and very
easily into the compiler and one of the
main packages that make it possible is
this cassette library
how it works is that you define a new
context in which you execute functions
and in this context you can completely
rewrite anything that gets called and
any function that gets called in this
context so for a simple thing there's
this pre-hook function that gets
executed before any call and I'm just
using it to print what I'm calling next
and if I then multiply four exam
executes a multiply in this context I
will see the whole call stick for this
and if you're saying now wow that's a
lot of function calls for a simple
multiply that's true because there's a
whole promotion engine and things like
that but this actually gets compiled
down to be as fast as C because all of
these are free abstractions in the
compiler what you can also do is you can
actually change the implementation of a
function here I'm just doing something
really silly
I just override the convert function and
multiply it by 3 which completely
changes our result but this is very
powerful and can be used for
implementing differential automatic
differentiation and things like that or
also there's a package that uses this to
rewrite loops to execute them on the GPU
and things like that and this all just
works based on the giulia just-in-time
compiler and it's as fast as if you
would execute it directly the resulting
code I also wrote a interactive library
it's super early this is probably the
first time I'm showing it
I'm hoping it's still running ah it's
not
the problem is next Journal shuts down
the runner after 20 minutes and I guess
it's has been 20 minutes
this needs to communicate with the Julia
process in order to update the values
but how it works is you can just use the
marked markdown syntax pretty much and
you can interpolate sliders and values
into it and they will just update
accordingly so this should update the
plot in here yes much like PI widget
it's very similar it also runs and
Jupiter also runs in the Adam IDE and
you can also just serve it as a webpage
all right I guess this is probably going
through some people's mind right now so
yeah it's really hard to leave a
language if you already all your
colleagues work in it you have a lot of
libraries you really like but if you're
really serious about Julia and want to
offer your colleagues to still work with
your packages that you've write enjoy
it's possible there's good news and bad
news there's possible is the good news
the bad news is that it's not that used
at the moment so I had quite a few
problems getting this to run but in the
end it was running so there's the sugar
package in Python you can just start
importing any Julia package much like
the PI call example before but the other
way around then I've wrote a bit of
wrapper code just to make it a bit nicer
to use and then you can just call this
is my plotting library you can just call
it from Python with numpy arrays and
with keyword arguments and everything it
works now what's bad
you probably already see here 88 seconds
at execution time which is really bad
for a language that I just sold us to be
super fast this is all compilation time
and yeah that's really bad
but there you can compile it ahead of
time but it still doesn't work
completely it's a bit of a hassle so
people just do it if they're really
forced to if they want to deploy it or
things like that and actually it's not
such a big problems for most your
developers because if you're developed
locally you will just start doing a
one-time load or your packages and from
there on you will only compile this so
any new function you define and that
will be instantly and so after
everything compiled you will have pretty
much the same latency as in Python but
it can get annoying especially if you
try to compute something in the cloud
where where it's expensive to just waste
computations and things like that but
yeah deploy is also bad it's related
because usually you want to compile
things ahead of time if you deploy it
it's a work in progress or some people
are already deploying Julia
to different platforms but they had to
do it with a lot of manual work to get
it running and I'm actually working on a
package to improve this but it's a slow
progress because I don't have that much
time other people are working on it but
it's happening and that brings me to my
last point when should I use Chuya I
think library authors that need
high-performance and complex
mathematical code I I think I can say
you can immediately start using using
julia because it's really fun to write
libraries in it especially if they're
from scratch and not super large with
lot of compilation times and if you want
smooth deploy and smooth ahead of time
compile
compilation I think that's probably
ready in one to two years and the
compiler team is working a lot on having
a half interpreted mode and half
compiled mode so then you will get the
best of Python and Julia in one language
but that will take some time and I think
in three to five years you can probably
expect that most problems and the echo
system are fixed probably some
ecosystems will still not be as nice as
in Python because nobody invest the time
in it but I think in the really serious
areas we will have it in one to two year
years all right thank you I don't have a
session share any questions now okay
good when I started learning Python I
didn't know about pep eight so I wrote a
lot of code that didn't look nice when
you begin in Julia is there anything
about code style you should know when
you begin if there's anything about code
style yeah I think there's some no
ghosts people usually some people come
from other line object-oriented
languages and write to the forum how can
I write object-oriented and Julia and
everyone is just like no don't do this
we have something better and there are
some style guides out there they're a
bit ignored I think but the document the
official documentation has some comments
about what you should avoid and what you
should be doing like when you should
type your signatures of your functions
and things like that
other questions hey from your
presentation as far as I understood you
can directly inherit from classes in
patent is that correct and can you a
little bit elaborate so how that works
do you get all that you have in patent
like everything to define upper they
hiearchy in Julia and how you call that
like just for raping the my brains
around it yeah so I think how it works
is that it this macro actually generates
Python code to find a Python class and
whatever function you passed in there or
defined and there will get passed to the
Python class as a as a Julia function
that then gets called as a method inside
the class so it's very similar to
passing a callback function and then you
just have a thin juhi of wrapper around
that python class on the Jewess ID but
it takes like some like python engine
and it goes through regular by a Python
distribution that you have so you need
to have both or like how's that getting
together I need to need both both of
what so it's just taking Python code and
doing in the bite and distribution
itself so does it go through bite an
engine - ah
yes yes you need to have a path
installation okay thanks any other
questions okay thanks for the tow sorry
there's no question
Thanks so one thing I really like about
Python is that the code is very readable
mm-hmm
and just judging from the examples that
you showed it didn't look as read but
I'd say to me so would you say that so
in the beginning there's like is it hard
to grasp just the syntax was so is there
like a learning steep learning curve
I guess it depends on where you come
from but yeah I've I haven't been coming
from pison so I can't completely judge
it I just know that there are a lot of
maths examples where the math looks much
nicer in Julia of course if you're
really set on object-oriented
programming will it will usually take
some time to grasp how to write things
in Julia yeah I think usually the syntax
is as nice and comparable as pies and
there are fewer things like people don't
like the and and Julia but I think
that's nitpicking
if you've write an end or if you leave
it open weave write and and don't have
any like tap problems and Julia so I
don't know I think these are minor
things but they're definitely some
examples
I should have linked them all I will
probably update the slides where where
you can really see how how much nicer
you can sometimes it's a problem in
Julia of course they're probably the
other way around sometimes but yeah okay
well thanks for your talk all right
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]